we're learning more tonight about what
the Obama Justice Department ordered
federal lawyers to do and not to do
concerning the Hillary Clinton email
investigation chief intelligence
correspondent Catherine Herridge tells
us in sworn testimony on Capitol Hill
one of the insiders told lawmakers what
she was told
during closed-door testimony last summer
former FBI lawyer Lisa page said the
Obama administration's Justice
Department advised the FBI not to pursue
the gross negligence statute for Hillary
Clinton in the mishandling of classified
information former US attorney and House
Republican John Radcliffe led the line
of questioning about the statute known
as 18 USC 793 Ratcliffe you're making it
sound like it was the Department that
told you you're not going to charge
gross negligence because we're the
prosecutors page interrupted that is
correct
Paige's testimony appears to conflict
with then FBI director James Comey
recommendation in July 2016 against
criminal charges for Clinton what I can
assure the American people is that this
investigation was done honestly
competently and independently no outside
influence of any kind was brought to
bear the republican-led House Oversight
and Judiciary Committee investigation
and did in January with Democrats now in
control the committee's new ranking
Republican made the page transcript
public the transcript releases show an
inherent two-tier system one in which
Hillary Clinton gets the treatment that
she got where there was actually a first
concern that they were going to charge
her and then with Loretta Lynch in
charge before she recused herself made
it very clear that that was not going to
happen the tip-off came from a chart
drawn up by federal investigators
assigned to the Clinton case known as
major exam Fox News has confirmed that
the chart listed possible federal
statutes for prosecution next to gross
negligence was a notation quote DOJ not
willing to charge this only known cases
are military
cases when accused lost the information
in response to the page revelations the
president tweeted the transcripts quote
make the Obama Justice Department look
exactly like it was a broken and corrupt
machine the page transcript also
confirms Fox's earlier reporting the
page testified Russia
was still unproven with special counsel
robert muller was appointed Brett cotton
thank you